Hey it's me Destin.
So a lot of you may not know, because you're new to
Smarter Every Day, but I have a sister who lives in West Africa as a peace corps volunteer
and I went and helped her teach math and science. Every once in a while I like to upload a video
because I learned a lot. Hope you enjoy.
[african music]
Morning. You would not believe
how useful frisbees are. We had a frisbee we were going to play with the kids,
and we asked for some food in the morning and this lady
served Stevo his cassava and beans
in a frisbee. She thought you brought your own plate didn't she?
[laughs]
So we're just
rolling with it.
Fish and rice?
This is cassava and beans.
OK this morning we used your frisbee as a plate to eat cassava and beans,
what are we using it for today?
- Surgical prep.
(Destin) What?
-Surgical Prep.
-What do you mean?
- I mean it's got antiseptic soap in it with water and we're using it to wash hands before we touch
a wounded area.
-Oh. That's wonderful.
(Destin) So what you're saying is a frisbee is one of the most versatile things in the world?
- Absolutely
- I mean we don't have to say it, you can see it.
(Destin) Let me zoom in on your hat there... yeah
- A little pitch for ultimate frisbee huh?
(Destin) This is a pitch for ultimate frisbee in third world countries. [laugh]
(Stevo) It's about more than just sport.
(Destin) Yeah it's about helping people. Happy people.
Dedi you happy? You happy?
(Sister) Tell me when you're ready.
-That's such a dad thing to do.
[Destin] How else were we gonna get that done?
- I know.
I'm just glad it was you and I didn't have to do it.
(Destin) Feel better?
Good. I'm sure that sucker helps too.
(Sister) The lolly pop is sweet?
[laughs]
(Destin) is sweet?
Lolly pop help small small? Yes.
OK squeeze little.
(Sister) My face is stuck like this.
(Destin) Hey dog you're not sterile.
We're thinking frisbee can take off here in Africa if we could just train somebody to do it.
So we've already showed you the several uses for frisbees, so
here we're trying to train our first West African
ultimate frisbee member.
Almost.
Keep trying.
Send him deep.
[laughs]
[music]
[ Captions by Andrew Jackson ]
captionsbyandrew.wordpress.com
Captioning in different languages welcome.
Please contact Destin if you can help.